mark mccloskey will though he now faces
four years in prison
and up to a ten thousand dollar fine for
the crime
of defending himself when no one else
would mark mccloskey joins us tonight
mark thanks so much for coming on i
can't imagine how you
feel like you've woken up in a country
you don't recognize
tell us where you are right now legally
if you would
well it's a totally upside down world
tucker the people that broke into my
neighborhood
they're all trespassing the the guy that
recruited it that planned this event
said the next day that he intended to
break the law that it was his
he needed to break laws in order to send
his message none of those people are
arrested
none of those people are charged the
prosecutor the circuit attorney has
apparently decided that her job
as a prosecutor isn't to keep us safe
from criminals
but to keep the criminals safe from us
it's it's a bizarre
upside-down world i've been a little
irritated by this process until today
now i'm just flat out pissed off i mean
this is this has gotten to be outrageous
well you should be afraid too i mean the
force of the state is coming down on you
for exercising the most basic right that
exists it's a natural right the right of
self-defense
are you going to stay in a place that
seeks to put you in prison for defending
yourself
you know everybody has to stand up and
and do what's right and
i'm not going to be bullied i'm not
going to be intimidated
the left the mob uses social
intimidation
and threats to get people to knuckle
under and apologize for doing what's
right
and we're not going to apologize for
doing what's right we're not going to
back down and we're not going to move
people need to stand up wake up and
recognize this for what it is
it's a concerted effort to destroy our
way of life to change the fundamental
basic problem
social contract to do away with
capitalist democracy and replace it with
mob rule encouraging violence protecting
the criminals and prosecuting people
that try to defend themselves against it
it's a bizarre world
it's time for people to wake up and pay
attention to it has anyone explained
what you were supposed to do in a
situation where the police would not
respond
they would not come to protect you
despite the fact you pay them and
private security wouldn't come either
probably for fear of being sued
what were you supposed to do once people
break in and start threatening you
well you know what what various
commentators have suggested is
we should have just gone inside and
filmed them with our cell phones
well do you want to have 300 people
inside your house
breaking stuff setting fires and killing
you or would you rather stop them when
they're outside
we chose to stop them from coming in
what's going to happen now i mean do you
have a fear of going to prison
you know i don't know i'm i've i have
very little familiarity with the
criminal process
we've gotten support now from the white
house house on down
governor parsons the senator eric
schmidt our attorney general
it seems like the only person in the
united states that thinks we did
something wrong
is our circuit attorney but she's the
same person that led out of jail
everybody that was responsible for the
looting and fires and destruction
of following the george flory death in
the city of st louis the only people
that
she wants to prosecute are the people
that defended themselves against it
and nobody else to my knowledge so
you've been a target of crime
you haven't backed down you've gone on
television repeatedly
people know where you live and the state
has now confiscated your firearm so you
can't protect yourself
on what grounds did they do that those
were legally registered as far as i
understand
yeah i guess in the technicality of the
law is they have to determine whether or
not the
uh the weapons were readily capable of
being uh
you know fatal or uh causing
serious bodily harm and so they have to
take them and test them and that sort of
thing and there'll be
some revelations that come out about
that but the bottom line is
that you know the police i've said this
before the police had came out to issue
the warrant
didn't want to have to do it they knew
that they were just doing their job they
were very polite about it
but nonetheless you're right i mean they
they
present the mob to our door and then
strip of our ability to defend against
it
it's almost unbelievable i appreciate
your coming on tonight and godspeed to
you and your wife and
and we'll be following this of course
mark mccloskey thank you
thank you tucker